breaking news in der tat und sie kommen
aus moskau meine damen und herren einer
der engsten berater von wladimir putin
verlässt offensichtlich das land
außerdem ist der ministerpräsident also
der regierungschef und auch der
verteidigungsminister seit mehreren
tagen nicht mehr gesehen worden bei uns
ist unser russland experte peter tiede
peter was könnte dahinterstecken
also entweder ein kreml blieben oder
aber anzeichen für säuberungen also dass
anatolij tschubais ist das ist jemand
der wahl sein berater für nachhaltige
entwicklung klingt jetzt erst mal banal
aber er war gleichzeitig auch chef einer
mikro elektronik firma einer
beteiligungsgesellschaft cross name und
vor allem ist ein weggefährte von
wladimir putin beide haben in den 90er
jahren unter anatoli sobtschak dem
reform bürgermeister damals in sankt
petersburg karriere gemacht haben da
auch zueinander gefunden kennen sich
seitdem um putin hat ihn sich quasi als
berater für nachhaltige entwicklung
geholt der hat heute also heute bekannt
geworden er hat seinen job gekündigt
sein berater job offensichtlich auch
sein job perez nano und hat das land
verlassen
da machen wir mit shooting das ist der
ministerpräsident und der
verteidigungsminister soldo kennen wir
vom langen tisch bei wladimir putin da
sei es ganz hinten irgendwo saßen dann
in den letzten wochen immer der
außenminister sergei lavrov und
scheidung ist jetzt seit knapp zwei
wochen also seit mehr als zehn tagen
nicht mehr öffentlichkeit und tv gesehen
worden und mit ihm auch nicht das kann
für säuberungen am kriegs ruf von ladina
putin sprechen wir haben wir die
berichte darüber dass mehrere ranghohe
geheimdienstoffiziere auch der chef der
fünften abteilung des fsb das ist quasi
der von putin selbst geschaffene
parallel außen geheimdienst
auslandsgeheimdienst dass der unter
hausarrest steht dass mehrere andere
verhaftet worden sind und wenn jetzt der
verteidigungsminister der quasi
zuständig war für die sogenannte blitz
kriegsstrategie in der ukraine also 34
tage krieg und dann ergeben sich die
ukrainer dass das nicht geklappt hat
dafür ist schon gut verantwortlich und
offensichtlich hat man ihn zumindest aus
der öffentlichkeit entfernt wie weiter
jetzt entfernt von das was mit ihm
passiert ist wissen wir nicht auch nicht
was mit dem regierungschef ist sollten
beide freiwillig nicht mehr öffentlich
auftreten ist das auch ein zeichen also
zumindest stimmt da einiges nicht und
dann kommt jetzt gerade noch eine
weitere meldung rein und zwar
mit video der mann mit dem putin immer
bäumchen wechsel dich gespielt hat auf
den präsidenten und den
ministerpräsidenten stuhl der warnt
jetzt vor der fall vor dem sturz von
platini putin also wenn der schon warnen
muss vor dem sturz von wladimir putin
und er sagt die führung in moskau werde
niemals die zerstörung russland zu
lassen da sollten die usa ihre ziele
erreichen dass ich propaganda die da die
dilemma läuft
könnte der welt eine dystopische krise
bevorsteht also eine vernichtende krise
bevor schon eine dunkle krise
bevorstehen mit videos zeichnet auch das
welt geld auch das bild einer welt nach
putin die auf den zusammenbruch
russlands folgen würde die zerstörung
des größten landes der erde könnte zu
einer instabilen führung in moskau
führen die über eine maximale anzahl von
atomwaffen verfüge pünktchen pünktchen
pünktchen
also mit videowand uns davor dass wir
die mir putin gestürzt werden würde
würde das atomwaffenarsenal der russen
quasi frei zur verfügung stehen oder
angewendet werden können das ist das was
die propaganda immer schon gemacht hat
das gesagt ja aber stellt euch mal eine
welt ohne oder in russland ohne putin
vor ihr wisst nicht was danach kommt das
ist jetzt die warnung mit der atomwaffen
keule also wir haben ganz offensichtlich
im kreml um den kreml herum bestimmte
bewegungen und wir haben wirklich dunkle
finstere drohung vita titel danke für
diese erklärungen